[Music]
so as a good practicing Christian you
wouldn't go to a sales and it would
probably be safe to say that you
wouldn't play with a Ouija board right
you don't a balloon magic and sorcery
but could it be possible that you do
engage in these activities simply by
being a passive observer are you
participating in these forbidden
practices by taking pleasure in this
since the dawn of cinema the Hollywood
industry has been a spiritualism
peddling machine today
it's so commonplace that most people
don't even bat an eye I'm sure there's a
lot of well-meaning Christians who have
seen their fair share of occult movies
despite them having questionably dark
themes many of these films even go as
far to reveal there's a great battle
between light and darkness yet for a lot
of sincere Christians there seems to be
a disconnect between what the Bible
warns against and one's appetite for
entertainment have you noticed the
increase of supernatural elements in
movies in recent years it seems to be
the main ingredient by constant exposure
you become desensitized to it and
therefore familiar with the dark
spiritual underworld take for example
the ever increasing popular comic film
series The Avengers it's a non-stop mix
of supernatural power and sorcery that
dazzle the senses if you ask fans how
they'll receive these box-office Giants
they'll respond with an overwhelming
the movie creators have planned for
years how to bring their stories
together with one goal to battle a super
villain named fan OHS what we always try
to do at Marvel Studios is we're
building the cinematic universe is look
at the big picture how can things relate
across movies and across years Avengers
infinity war is the culmination of the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe as
started in May of 2008 with the release
of Iron Man 1 and it really is an
unprecedented culmination of a series of
films interlinked together which at the
time had never been done before and for
us the important thing is making it all
come together we know they're gonna face
Thanos we've been setting that up since
Avengers 1 who came from a group in the
universe called the Eternals he seeks
supreme power and is on one personal
mission to acquire all the Infinity or
soul stones is sometimes they're
referred to according to the Marvel wiki
each stone has certain powers associated
with them like controlling the souls of
the living or the dead ultimate control
over life in the universe the ability to
see in the past or the future
omnipresence or the ability to read
thoughts and dreams or the ability to
create anything along with the access to
manipulate all forms of energy do any of
these powers sound familiar to you in a
biblical sense only the God of heaven
has these abilities yet in the fictional
world of Marvel these superpowers are
acquirable making its holder to be like
God
is alpha being in the universe I also
don't think it's by chance that this
evil Supreme Being comes to earth on a
warship called the sanctuary - there's
just too many parallels here to be a
mere coincidence since the beginning of
time man has been deceived to believe
that through sorcery and magic one could
attain godlike abilities
God gave frequent warnings not to have
anything to do with these dark arts
Leviticus 19 31 says do not turn to
mediums or seek out spiritists for you
will be defiled by them I am the Lord
your God God is crystal clear
we are defiled by magic and sorcery
Deuteronomy 18 10 through 12 calls
sorcery and witchcraft and abomination
which is the strongest verbage God can
use to illustrate his divine hatred for
it
superhero movies are notorious for these
elements being incorporated into their
storylines
one such movie that sucked a lot of
Christians into its hype
despite its questionable content was the
Black Panther the movie glorified all
kinds of pagan worship with the main
characters displaying the practice of
juju a spiritual belief system that
incorporates objects such as amulets and
spells in a religious practice basically
witchcraft
there was ancestral worship for example
when the Kings mother called upon the
ancestors to bring back her son
bust I'm here with my son - John
there was worship of the Egyptian
goddess bast there was animal
shape-shifting like when the Black
Panther changes into his animal form
which is also a form of witchcraft
there's necromancy the practice of
communicating with the dead in the days
of ancient Israel these practices were
so despised they were worthy of death
the Bible has very strong language to
warn against these practices Leviticus
20 verse 6 says and the soul that
turneth after such as have familiar
spirits and after wizards to go a
whoring after them I will even set my
face against that soul and I will cut
him off from among his people
no Christian wants to think that God
would set his face against our souls
those are pretty harsh consequences for
engaging in such practices my suggestion
you should stay far away from them don't
support them with your money your eyes
or your attention so in the light of
this here are some upcoming movies that
you should probably scratch off your
must-see lists
a house with a clock in its walls
produced by Steven Spielberg's
production company called Amblin
entertainment is nothing shy of satanic
it's interesting that it's based on the
beloved children's classic written by
John Bel Air's
and illustrated by Edward Gorey it's
quite a scary thought to think that this
is children's material the writer of the
Harry Potter series JK Rowling is back
at it again with her newest occult
agenda in the children's film fantastic
beasts and where to find them
part two ironically it's said of the
main character I know he's working under
your orders
what do you have to say for yourself
Dumbledore if you'd ever had the
pleasure to teach him you'd know newt is
not a great follower of orders I know
someone else who's the king of not
following orders I also find it
interesting that in the trailer for the
film it asks the question who will be
able to stand against the darkness are
they suggesting that the only way to do
so is to use Witchcraft and Wizardry
might want to mark this one off your
list as well because my Bible tells me
in Ephesians 6:13 that the only way to
stand against the darkness is to put on
the full armor of God and when that evil
day comes you may be able to stand your
ground the helmet represents salvation
Jesus is your salvation the breastplate
represents righteousness Jesus is your
righteousness the belt represents truth
Jesus is the definition of truth the
shoes are the gospel of peace Jesus is
the Prince of Peace the sword is the
Word of God and the whole book points to
Jesus that means the only way to stand
against the darkness is to put on Jesus
Disney is one of the biggest peddlers of
the occult they have six films that will
hit the box-office this year out of
these six films all of them have
elements of the occult that's 100
percent it's not family-friendly anymore
folks the devil is preparing for his
final deception and spiritualism is
preparing the way the Bible gives clear
instructions so that we will not be
caught off guard and be deceived
thank Satan it's some team
the only way to withstand this delusion
is to know the truth and the truth is
only found in the Bible you must not
only hear what it says but you must
become a doer of the word if it warns
you against engaging in spiritualism
then it would be wise to heed its advice
2nd Thessalonians chapter 2 verse 9 says
even him whose coming is after the
working of Satan with all power and
signs and lying wonders and with all
deceivableness and unrighteousness in
them that perish because they received
not the love of the truth that they
might be saved and for this cause God
shall send them a strong delusion that
they should believe a lie that they all
might be damned who believed not the
truth but had pleasure and
unrighteousness movies are powerful they
influence the viewer and leave a lasting
impression upon the mind
1st Timothy 4 describes a group of
people that once had the faith but left
it because of seducing spirits don't
fall prey to Satan's devices if it has
spiritualism or the occult in the films
don't watch them the world is getting
darker and it's only by the true light
which is Jesus not the occult will guide
us through these trying times I leave
you with this thought from the Apostle
John John 3:19 says and this is
condemnation that light has come into
the world and Men loved darkness rather
than light because their deeds were evil
hey everybody thanks for checking out
our video you know we designed these
leds to help you think about the
spiritual impact that some of these
films have upon your life if you like
this kind of content you know hit the
subscribe button below if you want to
help us produce more of this content
then check out our patreon page got a
lot of cool perks there and also if you
liked any of the b-roll clips we got
them from video mission comm it's a cool
new website where you actually can get
some neat biblical reenactment footage
super cost effective links in the
description below check it out
you